[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
In Numbers 23:19, it says he has full
knowledge of songs. Right. Yeah. And
then 147 it says Jesus is a man. He
calls himself a son and he doesn't know
everything. Christians will say that
this is when he took on the body and he
took on attribute of a man. But doesn't
this contradict 3:6 where the Lord says
he does not change if Jesus is son of So
if Jesus is son of God the all powerful
right he never committed sins. So why
was he not baptized? Why was he not
baptized? Why was he baptized? He's
gone. No because he's he's fulfilling
Oops. Oh no my
He's fulfilling all requirements, all
righteousness. So, like for example,
even though Jesus didn't sin, he still
followed the Mosaic law perfectly. But
why does Because we need him to. I mean,
you know, Jesus, could he see? Who?
Jesus. Could he see? Could Jesus see?
Yes. Yes. Could he walk? Yes. Could he
talk? Yes. But God doesn't walk seek at
all. Yes, he does. But he does. He's not
not in a man way, but literally one of
the names of Allah is the allseeing, all
hearing, but like not it's like it's not
human.
Human. Okay. So then so then we got to
like break this down then you know cuz
the Quran does talk about how Allah he
has eyes and he sees he has ears and he
hears and he also created Adam with his
hands you know so if he created Adam
it's like I don't know metaphorically
it's not physically he did it like it's
like no one knows what God looks like no
one knows what like stuff about God we
know he's a merciful he's a forgiving
and these 99 names they're only these
nine names do you believe he's all
powerful. Yeah. Yeah. So, if he wanted
to, could he come in a form of a human
if he wanted to? No need to come. I
agree. I I would say that there's no he
doesn't need to do that. But if he
wanted to, could he?
I answer that because I don't think like
of course like Yeah. If if he's all
powerful, he could, right? But like you
can't just I can't just say like God's a
human like No, I I agree. I'm just
saying if if God since because like this
is where we can agree like this is where
we have common ground is that we believe
that God is all powerful. He can do
whatever he wants, right? So if he
wanted to come in a human form, he could
do that if he chose to do that.
We agree the the question would be why
would he? That's the next question. But
first, I just want to make sure that we
are on the same page that he could if he
wanted to. Yeah. Can I just explain
about Islam? Sure. So I just want to say
what what did you pull up? I'm pulling
up everything I wrote.
You said you wrote this before cuz I do.
Oh, a level. Yeah. Okay. So I I would
like to actually go through what you
wrote like step by step and you know see
if we can fix stuff. So you know in
Islam firstly we believe in which is
like the un the unification of Allah.
Yeah. So Islam teaches us that like
Allah is one without partners without
images. And in the Quran in 11214 it
says he is Allah the one Allah's eternal
refuge. He's neither begets nor is born
nor is there to him and any equivalent.
Yeah, we don't basically believe in any
idol or creator.
So, we just like basically sit down.
Yeah. And we just pray to the landlords
like there's like obviously ways of
doing it because in the prophet's time
like I don't know what you guys call it
in the Bible. Um yeah, you can just say
the in the prophets prophet's time. in
the prophecy where prophet times um
there was obviously prophets like Adam,
Adam and Eve, like all of them like
Moses, Jesus, they were sent down
obviously different I don't want to
disrespect any trust me it's okay you
can be as you could be as real as you as
you want like obviously different
religions have different perspectives
but in Islam's perspective it was so God
put everyone in this world for a reason
like it's exactly so Christianity
believe that as well also obviously
Adam, Adam and Eve, they were brought to
his life because of you guys believe he
ate after they ate the fruit. Same
thing. Same thing. So Allah kicked them
out of paradise, right, for disobeying.
Yeah. So they got kicked out of
paradise, right? So God brought them to
um obviously this life as a test to test
them to test the faith of how much they
would repent and a lot of things
actually. So they had obviously kids,
twins, what was his name?
and for us it's
and obviously they were sent down and
this is when sin started when they had
jealousy jealousy and after Adam and all
murder so sis I want to let you I'm I'm
pretty familiar with like the the story
of Islam but I want to I just want to
ask you about just when it talks about
the concept of God you know do we both
agree or all three of us do we agree
because God is all powerful if he wants
that he could take on a human form if he
chose to. Well, yeah. The question is
why would he, right? Yeah. So, the so
the answer is yes, he could, but why
would he in the first place, right? But
to be honest, I don't know cuz inside
that kind of contradicts to, you know,
the oneness of God. He wouldn't cuz he's
still one God. But then like you can't
be a human. Yeah. Like you can't
associate God with being a human person.
Why not? Human died. Jesus died. Jesus
got But remember this. Notice what Jesus
says here. He says, "No one can take my
life from me. I lay it down myself." He
says, "I lay it down and I'm going to
pick it back back up again." So death
couldn't even hold him. That's what
Jesus says. But it's like, why did God
even get crucified? How very That's a
good question. All right. So let me let
me tell you even the why. Maybe the why
might make a little bit more sense.
Okay. Okay. So here's the reason why.
Okay. The whole point is that one, God
doesn't need to do anything. He does it
for us. Okay. Now, this is what God has
laws, right? He has commandments. He has
laws. And so, according to his law, the
Israelites, you guys know how they used
to give a sacrifice for their sins.
Okay? They used to have to do this all
the time. They has to always give a
sacrifice cuz they always kept sinning.
So, God's plan was is to send one final
sacrifice that eliminates it all so that
they don't have to keep giving
sacrifices and so that they're in God's
good graces. So the only way to do that
is to reconcile man back to himself is
that he came down as man's
representative to give his life as a
sacrifice so that man could be let go
free. So it's it's love
um before Jesus came to earth and got
crucified. Mhm. Like wait so you guys
believe Jesus is like the one God. Do
you guys believe you guys believe in one
God? Right. That's right. And you guys
believe Jesus. Yes. So before he got
crucified, if he came down from all the
Holy Spirit, he's he's God. He's he's
the word. You know how the Quran says
that Jesus is is the word of of Allah.
The kalimat like a spiritual like do you
know? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's he's a he's
a spiritual form. He didn't have a a
human body or whatever. He he a
spiritual form like the difference. So
how does that mean? So you guys believe
in one god. One second. That's like a
Christianity. If you guys believe in one
God, yeah, why is there Jesus and the
Holy Spirit and stuff? Because so it's
it's like this when you have like um
it's very similar to that's what Well,
it's very like God has God has his word
and he has his spirit, right? His word
that comes forth from him and his spirit
that comes out from him, right? That he
brings out. So that's what that's what
is the Bible teaches. You have God, you
have his word and you have his spirit.
His word is eternal and uncreated,
right? We believe the same thing. His
speech is uncreated, right? So his word
and his reason, his wisdom is a is is
personable with him. And you have his
spirit that also knows his mind and his
will and his emotions. So that's that's
why there's the Holy Spirit, his word,
Jesus, and then the father. When you
guys pray, Mhm. Well, like you guys
know, what do you do? We we if we call
it God, just like if I were just to say,
"God, help me." You know, I'm invoking
the I'm invoking God, who is the father,
the father, son, and holy spirit. The
father and the son. Yeah, I'm invoking
all of them. Jesus. Wait, you know
Testament Jesus? Why don't you let me
explain this really quick? Okay, you're
ready to get there. No, it's okay. But
because these are good questions. These
are good questions. Okay, so imagine
like for example, um the Bible says that
God is love. Okay, like so God is love.
Not that he's just loving, but he is
love. So he's the highest form of love.
Now, let me ask you this really quick.
What would you say is the higher form of
love? just selfish love that I just keep
to myself or love that I share with
another love that I share with another.
Right? Okay. So then that means that God
in his essence because God doesn't
depend on anybody else. Right? So God
within his own essence will have to have
at least shared love, a relation with
another. So that's why God exists as a
trinity because if God is a trinity then
within his own essence he has another
there's there's a multitude of persons
that share that love with each other
within the essence of God. So that's why
you have the father and then you have
the son and you have the holy spirit who
share this love with each other the
highest form of love you know. So that's
why we believe the truth. But if if
Allah like for example Allah in in Allah
is just one person, right? He's one God.
One person. Yeah. Well, when I say
person, I mean an intellect and having
will self-awareness, right? So he's one
consciousness. And so before creation,
Allah doesn't love anyone. He's not
sharing his love with anyone. It's just
himself. And so so by himself, he can't
have a greater form of love, which is
shared love. He has to depend on
creation in order to have a better
quality of love. So that's why
is not adequate. It's not enough for God
to truly be love. You know what I'm
saying? No, God is all loving perfectly.
God is all loving. It's just that with
obviously with you guys, you believe as
if I don't know how to explain that this
way, but my question was you know how
there's two Bibles, the Old Testament.
Well, it's one Bible. It's the Old
Testament and the New Testament. It's
all part of the changed because you know
Okay. Can I say it's been changed? Yes.
Because the difference between the Quran
doesn't say that. Wait, wait, wait.
Okay. The difference between Jesus and
God, right? Jesus died. Jesus was
tempted. Jesus was sin. Jesus was a man.
Did you Did you write this, too? Yeah.
So, you wrote all of this? Yeah. Jesus
has to grow and learn. Did you know it
says that God was tempted in the
wilderness? Hold on.
Jesus knew the salvation. Jesus slept.
Jesus was all powerful. Jesus, he was
all powerful. All of these are
misconceptions. Wait, God cannot die.
The difference is God cannot die. What?
Wait, let's let's do one at a time. Is
that okay? Okay, let's do the death
part. All right. So, death, death is
just separation of body and soul, right?
Yeah. Right. Okay. So, just because you
die, it doesn't mean that you cease to
exist, right?
Give me the
So, when you die, you don't just
disappear, right? you you move on to
either paradise or the hellfire, right?
So death is just a separation of your
soul leaving your body and going and
moving on. Yeah. Right. You with me so
far, sister? I don't know.
Seriously. So death death is just when
your soul moves on to the to the next
life. Okay. Now, when it talks about
Jesus dying, God, you're right that God
cannot die if if he he doesn't have a
body to leave. He doesn't have a a body
where his soul separates from. Yeah. But
if he takes on flesh, if he takes on a
human form, then he can leave that body
and exper like experience death in that
way. That's all death is. So the reason
why God can't die is cuz God doesn't
have a human body to die in. If he takes
on a human body, then he can experience
death. That doesn't mean he stops
existing. He still exists and he's still
ruling over everything. Yeah. Does that
make sense? Even in John 18, right? John
18. Okay. 118. It says, "No one has seen
God."
John 1:18. John 1:18. Okay. Old chapter.
Oh, but hold on a second. Have you Have
you read the verse? Yes. Okay. So, it
says that no one has seen God at any
time. The only begotten God who is at
the father's side, he has seen him and
made him known. So, the one who has,
it's talking about the father
specifically. Okay? Remember, there's
three persons. There's the father,
there's the son, the word, and then the
holy spirit. So, the one who hasn't been
seen is the father, and it's the son who
makes him known. That's okay.
What what do you think so far? Cuz
you don't know any other do you
understand why um why I said why he came
and and in the flesh in the first place
is cuz we kept sinning and you know we
had to keep giving sacrifices. He's the
final sacrifice who comes and represents
us. That's the reason why he did it.
Okay. So he did it for us cuz we needed
him to. Not that he needed it, but he
needed us to I mean we needed him to
come and represent us. Is it time to go?
So to wrap it up, guys, um just
spreading the gospel to some Muslim
sisters. You could tell they love their
religion. She had a bunch of notes and
different comparisons that she made
herself to, you know, basically refute
the claims of Christianity, but a bunch
of misconceptions that you usually get
from the Dava script. And so, as you saw
when we're breaking down the Dava
script, you know, there's not much for
her to go off of. So, yeah. So, guys,
just all keep in mind, not everyone
knows the gospel. Not everyone, they
just go by what they hear. And so, you
want to just compassionately give the
gospel and just um clarify some
misinformation. All right. See y'all on
the next one.
It's God. It's God.
[Music]